inna Stegman is usually sitting at her
desk this time of day but right now
she's getting in some exercise work
times here are flexible so I'm taking my
break now this really wakes me up after
concentrating all morning my energy
drops by midday when I get in a workout
I'm much more energized in the afternoon
it doesn't tire me out just the opposite
this fitness studio is part of a DDoS
strategy to create a work/life balance
at first glance the environment at
adidas looks more like a recreation area
in fact there are hardly any traditional
offices all employees have a laptop and
a mobile phone to do their work
wherever it makes most sense why not in
a beanbag chair
Jessica ma gold is preparing for her
next meeting with some designers they're
going over a new collection together
before splitting up again when I have a
job to do as long as it gets done it's
up to me how I go about it of course we
come together here when there's a
meeting but when I'm not having meetings
my schedule is pretty flexible we don't
have to punch the clock mati das is
headquartered in provincial Bavaria the
closest major city Nuremberg is about a
half hour's drive from here in order to
attract highly qualified employees the
company has to sweeten the deal as what
is a sort of regardless of what company
it is in today's work environment young
people expect a proper work/life balance
this is now common practice the bar has
been set quite high we're not the only
job provider offering perks like workout
rooms or flexible hours so we have to
make it really attractive for instance
the company provides a daycare called
world of kids 120 children spend the day
here while their parents work just next
door
except not vicodin I went back to work
pretty quickly after all three of my
kids were born eight weeks but I think
it's important to breastfeed for the
first nine months I was able to utilize
the nursing areas here this was possible
because of these great facilities for
the most part employees here can largely
determine their own working hours this
includes and not just for mothers
working from home once a week